今何位の見たことないのやっちゃおうと
そうね
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
すまんちょっとエレベーターが普及してる
からだっけ見て来てもいいですか
ちょっとダメだったら今日の映像を行え
ません
エレベーターと動いてます思っていません
ああ
高田上にも行けないあるっていう
歩いていく
振り返る
あー0とマジですなるほど分かりました
歩きます
歩きますねざいました
[音楽]
どうぞ
味ますしたしますしここが2回ハイブーツ
がんばるかー
ありがとうございません
がんばりまーす10ページからさっき会談
でいけと言われました
10回今ではエレベーターで行ってそこ
からたいなんですっ食べますここ動いてる
ぜいうはい
ここですねー
なる発頭
0ございますさえ行ってきますはい
ありがとうございましたはい頑張って
くださいパチンコ業界から
数台が空いています
こんにちははじめ社長です3月の中7日の
深夜かな震度6
今日の大きな地震がありました津波なども
起きてるみたいなんですけれども私は仕事
で東京に来ておりましてよなんかちょっと
今日撮影で疲れたんでプライベートの会員
制のサウナに入ってパーが入ってるときに
その地震が起きてしまって家に帰って切っ
たところなんですけれども僕がは東京で
住んでいる家の9市がほぼ全部定例してて
もう信号も消えてたりで交通を
めちゃくちゃ警察が出動してもうてで
技ってとか分からないでとかやってるなん
か不安になりながら家に帰ったら私の家も
定例していたという流れですそしてこれ何
を意味するかというとエレベーターも
止まっているんですねエレベーターを
止まっていてあの僕の家細かいことは言え
ないんですけども約
40回
ずっ階まではエレベーターでくれたんです
けどもここから約30回ですね
分かっていこうと思いますいきます
ん
やばいなーこれ
[音楽]
そんなことに慣れなんでてかおりの住ん
でるマンションに階段があることすら文字
を嗅いだぜてあると思いますけどどこに
階段がある方も全く知らなかったんでこう
いう緊急師が始めてですマンションとかに
住んでいる方はこういう近日エレベーター
止まっちゃうんでちょっと確認しておいた
方がいい気がしますどこに階段があるかと
かどこ地震で電気が止まってしまったら
どうやって下にを言えばいいのかとかこれ
まずでちゃんと調べておけばよかったなと
思って
公開してますねやばい
ちょっとちょっと待ってねー
ちょっと待ってねー
湯種のわー
[音楽]
やっぱ
目頭痛
20回が出来ました
あと半分
[音楽]
水やソーダはいろんなひとつ買ってんなん
ん
7分
あってくださいヤバイぞ
これ
ヤバイぞ
[音楽]
30回ができます
阿蘇10分
ヤバイぞ
エレベーターっ
すごいな
行こうか
それでちょっとあの家族とか友達とかと
安否確認しながら登ってます
もう1時半だよ明日も朝からちょっと撮影
がだよねほんと早いねたかったんですけど
兵で町もめちゃくちゃだしタクシーも
捕まらないし
もう地獄絵図でしたね東京はホント皆さん
の安全を
祈るだけです
そしてタワーマンションに住んでる方はん
覚悟してください
家なう
会マネー
つきました
ん
ただいまあれ
えっ
電気はついてるんだ
えっ全然丁寧サイズうちは停電というより
エレベーターが動かなくなってただけなの
か性をやった訂正しないスーツへハイあの
僕が住んでる区は結構素とか見たら
めちゃくちゃ停電したんで国よく丁寧せず
に今電気ついてるしエレベーターが止まっ
ただけ進んでるなと思いますよかった
福島とかか
石マッチてちなみか2位というわけで今回
はマジでほんとにもう
サウナ入って気持ちよくなって寝るだけっ
て思ってたんですけども
突然40階階段上らされたっていう動画
でした想像しなかったねなんか勝手にこの
家なら大丈夫だなと思ってて体はせないん
ですけどもエレベーターやっぱりその乙
たりすると本当に危ないんでやっぱり点検
だったりとかそういうので動かなくなって
たので階段を上らざるを得なかったって
いう動画でした地震とかの実被害じゃなく
てというな間接的な被害何も壊れてないん
ですけど結局エレベーターととまったり
停電が起きたりとか信号を受けるからもう
交通が大変になっていろんな想定してい
ない部分で影響が起きたりするんで自身は
皆さんそこはぜひあの気をつけて野菜ぼく
も猫が身を持って感じました
今日ゆっくりねーそうです
ben
ますあっ
[音楽]
はーる
el